this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to yet another episode of biographics
I'm your interim host Carl small and
today we're talking about mberg the
catcher who may have been a spy and
every video on this channel is based on
a script and this one is no different
and that script was written by one Larry
holsworth that you can follow the links
you can find below if you are inclin and
I've also had a message passed out from
the guys upstairs who pay my wages that
being that I have to say the words like
comment and subscribe before getting to
the meat of the video because analytics
show that me saying that makes all three
of those things more likely to
happen so the story of mberg is the very
definition of an enigma he was a
professional baseball player of somewhat
dubious abilities yet he managed to
remain in the major leagues for 15
Seasons he was fluent in several
languages including Japanese Cantonese
Hebrew the ancient Indo-European
language of Sanskrit he held degrees
from Princeton University Columbia
University and the sborn in Paris he
practiced law while remaining in Major
League Baseball as his offseason job he
never married leading to Wild
speculation regarding his sexuality both
during and after his life yet he held a
reputation According to some researchers
as being a Serial womanizer with a taste
for young girls including at one time
the daughter of a fellow baseball player
called Babe Ruth yes that Babe Ruth his
aidite nature led him to mingle with
leading socialites in Boston New York
and Washington DC all towns in which his
celebrity as a ball player helped open
doors yet as a student at Princeton he
had remained somewhat of a lone
ostracized due to his Jewish Heritage he
traveled extensively in the years before
World War II to Berlin to Moscow to
Paris to Tokyo to what was then known in
the west as P King now Beijing in China
One would expect then in 1930s of
America such activities and background
would have attracted the attention of
Jay Edgar Hoover's FBI because things
back then the they just sucked all right
and all these things would have been red
flax for Hoover in his quest to protect
America from communism yet a search of
the FBI's vaults of finals available
under the Freedom of Information Act
reveals no mention of Mo Berg it's as if
as far as the bureau was concerned he
never existed or perhaps they are simply
classified because the Central
Intelligence Agency acknowledges Berg
and contributions Enigma indeed here is
part of his
story Morris Berg was born in 1902 in
the Harlem neighborhood of New York City
his father Bernard Berg was an immigrant
from Ukraine then part of the sarish
Russian Empire his mother was a
homemaker both of most parents were
Jewish which for a time during his
childhood proved inconvenient by the
time he was 10 years of age his parents
had moved twice first to West Newark in
New Jersey and later to the neighborhood
of Ros Ville in Newark in moving Mo's
father sought out communities where
there were fewer Jews preferring to live
among Italian American immigrants Mo was
thus raised in an environment which
offered no real religious training at
all as a non-practicing Jew he did not
encounter the anti-Semitism which was a
factor in American Life at the time and
he didn't encounter these things until
much later in his educational career now
that career began kind of early because
according to Mo's claims later in life
he begged his mother to enroll him in
school before the day of his fourth
birthday in regard to his later baseball
career he first played organized
baseball for a team fielded in Roseville
by a Methodist epicop Soul church he was
just 7 years of age and played under the
pseudonym R wolf which is awesome at
Barista High School in Newark one of the
oldest public high schools in the United
States little bonus fact for you all
there Mo played under his given name he
played well enough to be named to an all
City team during his senior year and
usually played at third base it was at
baringer that Mo first encountered
difficulties such as being ostracized by
fellow students due to being Jewish
there were very few Jewish students in
the mostly Italian-American Community
which was the situation his father had
wanted when he' moved the family to
Roseville all those years prior Mo
graduated from baringer high school in
1918 just 16 years of age he then
studied for two semesters at New York
University when he also played a little
more baseball before he was persuaded to
enroll at Princeton University for the
rest of his life Mo Berg disregarded the
academic year he had attended in New
York referring to himself first and
foremost as a Princeton man he graduated
from that institution Magna lard with a
Bachelor of Arts in modern languages in
1923 he was fluent in German Greek
Italian Spanish French and extensively
studied Latin and Sanskrit he had also
excelled in baseball at Princeton
bringing him to the attention of the
Brooklyn Major League Baseball Club then
known as the Brooklyn Robins of the
national
league this feels distinctly different
from recording a video this feels like a
sponsor spot but my co-host isn't here
oh there you are Snoop let's talk about
Squarespace Brad Nisha tell me more
about Squarespace as I stroke my Sno so
Squarespace is an all-in-one website
platform you can use to create beautiful
websites so it's a website that makes
websites I love that I love the internet
sometimes well Squarespace is a very
easy to use an affordable solution if
you want to make a website and it ranges
from beginners to professionals and you
can do anything from sell time to
promote yourself to advertising various
things and folks out there might be
thinking well why do I need a website
you have a social media page that's a
website do you not like having your
social media page tied to a petty Tyrant
billionaire why not be your own Petty
Tyrant nonillionaire and make a website
that speaks to you as a person are you
an artist you sell stuff do you just
have like you know an Instagram page
where you take nice photos like hell
yeah the options for making a website on
Squarespace do appear to be practically
Limitless yes and one thing you can do
is you can add an extension to your site
which basically allows you to extend the
functionality so any any feature that
you want you can find an extension that
will allow you to do this so you got any
examples of this like what were the
features I could add to a website well I
imagine you could add an extension to
track certain things like if you want to
say how many people have read or looked
at something yes or if you may be wanted
to monitor the number of a particular
thing sold or how many people are
attending a certain class so as well as
extensions Squarespace also has its own
analytics page so you can keep track of
who's visiting your site and where
they're coming from and here's a thing
as well I'm just going to give people
out their Pro tip if you do make your
own website using Squarespace and the
links
below just you know take a break from
looking at analytics like guys we've
been in this content creation biz for a
long time now it's very very easy to
fall down that rabbit hole of watching
the number go up so yeah while it is a
very useful tool it's one that should be
used sparingly another great aspect of
Squarespace is also you can keep um in
contact with people who follow you or
subscribe to you with email campaigns
that's a very valuable tool for anyone
out there who creates things because you
worked hard to cultivate your audience
you should be able to contact them if
they choose to be contacted and as
people who work online it gets ever more
difficult to get people to click on the
things that you make even after they
specifically Say Hey I want to hear more
about this thing and an email campaign
just removes all the nonsense of a
middleman telling you that oh no um our
algorithm doesn't want to put this video
into someone's suggestion feed so thank
you to today's sponsor Squarespace check
out Squarespace at squarespace.com
biographics for 10% off on your first
purchase of a website SL doain using the
code biographics and a fun thing we've
been doing in these sponsor spots is
ending with a bonus fact you won't find
anywhere else in the video so would you
like to hear a bonus fact guys yeah okay
did you know there was a study that
proved nobody likes clowns so the story
here is that uh a couple of years ago
researchers at the University of
Sheffield went to the local Sheffield
children's hospital and conducted a
study on the kind of atmosphere that
would make children feel more at ease
because feeling at ease in a hospital
has been linked to you know recovery
times like if you feel like relax maed
and not terrified you're going to heal
better they conducted a survey with 250
children in the hospital to find out
what kind of Decor in the hospital would
make them feel most at ease and
literally every single child when asked
do you like clowns responded no they are
pretty terrifying to be fair and this
study actually earned the ey of like the
association of American
clowns who released a press release to
say that disagreed with the results of
the study saying that many children
found them
comforting in 1923 there were just 16
major league baseball teams and they
were concentrated in the north and
Central United States St Louis Missouri
held the Western most teams the
Cardinals in the National League and the
Browns in the American Chicago Boston
and Philadelphia likewise each fielded
two teams and New York had three the
Brooklyn Robbins they would not become
the Dodgers until 193 2 were a perennial
dmat in the National League nonetheless
they had a loyal fan base which team
owner charles eberts wanted to expand by
drawing interests from New York Region's
large Jewish Community the recently
graduated Princeton tiger signed with
the Robbins in June 1923 for a salary
equivalent to $86,000 today his first
professional gain took place later that
month with Mo appearing at third base
the position he usually occupied at
Princeton during the 1923 season he
exhibited a strong arm and good Fielding
instincts along with a distinct failure
to actually hit the ball at the end of
his first professional season he
declined to work on his baseball skills
or lack thereof and instead sailed to
Europe and had a residency in Paris he
enrolled at the sborn taking over 30
classes and in January 1924 he decided
just to travel through Italy returning
to America in 1924 Berg's lack of
hitting led to his demotion to the minor
leagues he remained mined in the miners
until April 1925 when his contract was
purchased by the Chicago White Socks the
white socks in Vision BG training as a
catcher for the 1926 season MO on the
other hand had decidedly different ideas
he informed the white socks that he
would arrive late to spring training in
1926 which he enrolled at the Columbia
Law School in New York he did not join
the team until late May played in only
41 games for the rest of the season and
returned to Columbia in the offseason
The Following Season the same situation
presented itself with Berg insisting on
remaining at Colombia until the end of
his turn in 1928 Mo finally reports to
the white socks on time and in better
physical condition he'd been in the last
few years following a stint at a lumber
camp in the the ader in the ading de I'm
going say in the mountains statistically
he had a much better season this time
eventually Mo played for five major
league teams and several minor league
teams as well before a knee injury
hampered both his speed and his ability
to complete long stint squatting as a
capture is required to do he also
completed his law degree receiving it
from Colombia in 1930 and by then he'
already passed the New York bar exam
allowing it to practice law in the
offseason he joined the New York firm of
satell and Canfield a Wall Street firm
to say Mo Berg's baseball career was
like luster is a little unfair he was
widely known that his hitting skills
were not up to his other abilities he
was also considered to be somewhat
strange with Casey stangle once saying
of him and I quote he's the strangest
man to ever play baseball late in his
career the Washington Senators invited
Berg to spring training senator's
Outfield Dave Harris was told of his
future teammate's ability to speak seven
languages reported equipping yeah I know
and he can't hit in any of
them
in the Autumn of 1932 1933 Berg joined
fellow ball players Lefty odou and Ted
Lions on a University tour of Japan
where they were to deliver lectures on
baseball odul and lions completed the
tour and returned to the United States
while Berg remained in Japan before
embarking on a tour which included
traveling to manua across India through
Egypt and eventually he found himself in
Berlin just as the Nazi party was
ascending to control of the German
government in 1934 several major league
players traveled to Japan play
exhibition games against Japanese teams
a Bruth Jimmy Fox Lou Garrick and other
future Hall of Famers made the trip
though Berg was not a player of that
caliber he was nonetheless invited to
participate he enthusiastically accepted
and contacted movie tone news in New
York regarding the trip movie tone was
one of several companies which presented
news reels and travel documentar shown
in theaters before a feature film was
screened Berg mentioned his previous
observations in Japan and suggested that
movie toone provided him with a 16 mm
movie camera as well as credentials as a
producer for the company and while in
Tokyo B claim to be visiting the
American ambassador's daughter whom he
did not know in the hospital which also
happened to be one of the tallest
buildings in Tokyo instead he went to
the roof of the building unescorted and
filmed the Tokyo Skyline and docks
visible from that during the trip Berg
was notified that the Cleveland Indians
had released him rather than continuing
the bar storming tour he embarked on
another extended trip including visiting
the Philippines and the Korean Peninsula
before traveling across the Soviet Union
and visiting Moscow if anyone curious
about why we mentioned the film at Burg
shots it's actually been credited by
some erroneously with helping the
planners of the doitt raid on Tokyo in
April 1942 Berg did not turn the film
over to the US government until the
summer of that year months after the
raid occurred it was during this bar
storming trip that Berg's reputation as
a womanizer caused concerns with Babe
Ruth Ruth's daughter accompanied her
father on the trip to Japan and they
sailed in the same ship as Burg the
daughter Julia was just 18 she became a
fixture on the ship's Dance Floor every
single night with Berg as her usual
partner according to Julia Berg and I
quote came on to me which rather
surprised me I must say thought he was
an interesting person Ruth was aware of
Berg's reputation among some ball
players as being an inveterate
womanizer in December 1941 the United
States was thrust into World War II
after the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor and the German declaration of war
just a few days later melberg maintained
many contacts in Washington where he was
a frequent guest at Embassy parties and
and other events during his playing days
he contacted Nelson Rockefeller and
joined the office of the coordinator of
the inter-american Affairs Berg's father
died in January 1942 and during his
son's baseball career he never once
attended a game in which Mel played not
in high school not at Princeton and not
in professional baseball Berg as was his
custom kept his thoughts regarding his
father to himself Mo Berg spent the
summer of 1942 preparing anti-propaganda
material to counter German and Italian
messaging in Central and South America
he also traveled as a Goodwill
Ambassador his gift for languages put to
good use he found the work boring and
lobbied for a position which required
more physical and direct action in
August 1943 he joined General William
Donovan's office of strategic Services
entering the Special Operations Branch
Berg's first assignment with the OSS was
monitoring from his office in Washington
events as they occurred in the Balkans
in particular he monitored activity in
Yugoslavia part of his duties involved
preparing operatives to embark on
missions in the region later in 1943 was
assigned to a plan under which Italian
physicists and scientists would be
induced into fleeing to the United
States those who were uncooperative were
to be kidnapped and brought to the
United States anyway in order to prevent
their services being exploited by the
germs he was known to the OSS as project
Larson so Berg traveled to Italy and
Switzerland in early 1944 where he
interviewed Italian Swiss and German
scientists and attempts to persuade them
to defect to the United States he was
also tasked with ascertaining from the
scientists just how much progress had
been made by wner Heisenberg and others
on the development of an atomic bomb and
here's where the story gets even more
strange so according to Berg and others
he was to attend the lecture armed with
a pistol and equipped with the requisite
Cai capsule should he be caught and in
this situation if Berg decided that the
Germans were close he was to make the
decision on his own to kill the
scientists and then himself if things
went a Ry Berg attended the lecture
decided that the Germans were not close
and allowed Heisenberg to live now
Berg's one documented accomplishment
while in Europe was his persuasion of
Italian aerodynamics expert Antonio
ferry to relocate the United States
Ferry was an international leader in the
development of SuperSonic flight and jet
propulsion Berg met with ferry in Rome
where they worked together in
translating captured documents and other
materials bur convinced ferry to
relocate to America where he was as
sconed at Langley Virginia within the
national advisory committee for
Aeronautics the OSS was disbanded in
September 1945 under an executive order
issued by President Harry Truman the
secret intelligence branch which had
controlled most of the programs that
employed mberg was absorbed into the
department of war in January 1946
President Truman created the Central
Intelligence Group which eventually
morphed into the Central Intelligence
Agency following the National Security
Act of 1947 by then melberg had left
government
service mberg drifted in the Years
immediately following World War II he
was out of baseball out of government
and showed little further interest in
either in 1951 he lobbied the CIA to
hire him and send him to Israel though
the CIA exhibited little interest in the
former ball player and LSS operative the
following year concerns over the Soviet
Union's development of atomic weapons
and the increased evidence they had
penetrated security over American atomic
energy programs LED them to approach
Berg once again According to some
sources of little documented evidence
supporting their conclusions we should
add Berg was asked to contact some of
his old sources in Europe regarding the
Soviet efforts according to those
sources Berg received the sum of
$110,000 to spy on the Soviet Union he
accepted the money traveled to Europe
and provided little in the way of actual
usable information the cia's official
online biography of berg does not
mention this effort though it does claim
that Berg and I quote provided the
United States with incredibly helpful
intelligence during World War II in 1947
President Truman announced that he would
award the medal of freedom the highest
civilian award in the United States to
Mo Berg Berg ultimately declined the
award reasoning that if he could not
discuss the activities for which he had
earned the award he did not want it in
the first place he mentioned possibly
writing and autobiography which
described his life in baseball and
Espionage but never really got around to
it one attempt by another writer to pen
his biography was aborted when Berg
withdrew his support for the project
apparently he had been offended when the
writer misu his subject from Mel Howard
of the three stes this C must be I'm no
imagine just the three stoes just
bumbling through World War II um just
like you know avoiding Calamity that's
that's fun Berg played in the initial
Hall of Fame game in 1939 and after his
retirement from baseball he gaed a
handful of votes of induction into the
Hall itself he is not enshrined there as
in Duck T but in 2018 the hall opened an
exhibit entitled mberg The Big League
spy which admittedly is way cooler the
exhibit included Declassified documents
from his days in LSS including from
Switzerland and Austria as well as
various items from his days on major
league ballfields in the 1950s Berg
largely stayed with his brother Sam
though he did sometimes rely on the help
of other friends and relatives when he
traveled as for how he funded these
various Adventures abroad we don't
really know how he did that because he
had no visible means of fin financial
support and when queried about how
exactly he made a living would usually
simply respond by going sh often
accompanying this with a wink which I
can't do but I'll try I'm really bad at
winking like this side of my face
doesn't work properly so wait no
sh that's that's what he'd do but you
know less lame for 17 years Mo lived
with his brother absorbed in his books
in newspapers and his own thoughts he
never married and though many former
teammates and Friends reported it is
extensive womanizing during his playing
years he never seemed to be in any
serious relationship with any one woman
for any significant length of time later
biographers speculated with flimsy
evidence we should add that he was a
closeted homosexual one such biographer
in his book The Catcher was a spy and in
the film later based on the book implied
a homosexual relationship in Japan
during his second trip to the country
but again there's little evidence to
support this assertation according to
Samberg Mo became morose and testy as
the 50s ran into the 60s and Sam finally
asked his brother brother to get the
hell out he had to draw eviction papers
to get Mo to leave and when Mo did he
relocated to his sister Ethel's house in
bellw New Jersey just to start the
process and new I guess in May 1972
mberg suffered a fall and had to be
rushed to hospital he died a few days
later his remains were cremated and
Ethel had his ashes sent to Israel where
they were either buried or scattered on
Mount scopus depending upon the source
as to his Service as a spy or as a
potential assassin which he claimed and
was reported on in countless websites
and videos it was much like the rest of
his life based on true events that were
greatly exaggerated through the
retelling usually by Berg himself he was
a mystery during his life and remains a
mystery in death there is no doubt that
he worked for the OSS during World War
II and in some dangerous circumstances
in Italy and Switzerland but the
accuracy of the tales in which he
prepared to assassinate a German
scientist seemed farfetched and have
little in the way of hard physical
evidence perhaps the catcher was a spy
what is certain though is that the
catcher was and still is a mystery one
of which the whole truth will likely
continue to elude both historians and
fans of baseball and you know YouTube
content creators like ourselves speaking
of which I hope everybody enjoyed this
YouTube video about Mo Berg if you did
leave a like a comment below with
suggestions for more topics for us to
cover feedback all that good stuff
subscribe for more like this follow the
author Larry holsworth on socials below
as my and my own if you want to you can
don't post on there much anymore you
know cu just everything happening right
now but I also have other channels fa
thing with car Smallwood and Wiki
weekends where you can find more content
from myself otherwise as I always like
to say I hope everybody out there has
the day they
[Music]
deserve